change why CRV danja lives change
organizations gai bian XI organization
tonight might change the world I'm very
very very very happy to be with you
today for different reasons first of all
because Stanford University is for sure
one of the best excellence Point
University Center in the world and it's
always good to be in the center of the
world
second because when the the Dean and
thank you for your word I remember when
I was in my first life I was a as a
variety manager racing in joinable in
the calamy circuit in the early 70
second reason is I was I was a student
at Columbia University just a couple of
years ago and so I was thinking when I
was there five years ago I took my I was
in university because I'm young at at
what you can see in my face and and I
hope you don't waste your time listening
at the water I'm very pleased to tell
you and third reason is because I have
to take care since at the beginning of
the clients of the future so I put a
small table outside in which you can you
can make just a signature and you can
have a Ferrari in a couple of years so
you have time to gain money and to be
and this is really I hope you can do it
talking no I was serious but talking
more serious I am proper I was prefer to
give you my vision of what leadership
means today because this is very
important and I hope my hope is that
when you will came out from this room
you can have some small motivations or
small ideas in some small examples that
can be useful for your future but when I
was listening at your dinner they may be
I have to do a mix between leadership
and Ferrari without make promotion to
Ferrari but who knows but as always but
mainly to give you an experience and not
a theoretically theoretically but an
experience that in which I really am in
touch with the everyday problems in a
small but believe me fantastic company
I always say to my people and not only
to my people well behind fantastic
products whatever the products are you
need fantastic people very easy to say
difficult to do and when you say we say
you know I receive some time journalists
coming from all over the world in which
and they ask me what is the secret of
the success of Ferrari I always answer
our products our people our clients and
I look the face of these a journalist I
listen I came from I don't know Hong
Kong Tokyo or WA to listen at this
stupid answer that is not a stupid
answer because behind these three
elements products people clients
there are many many subtitles in which
that very very important I want to say
crucial in every company and
particularly Ferrari to be leaders means
in my opinion mainly again three key
elements and you know you can have a
fantastic football player but they are
not a good a trainer fantastic
journalists that are not absolutely a
good publisher this doesn't mean that a
leader can be can have a 360 degrees
know how a leader in my view needs three
key elements number one passion behind
the red color of Ferrari there is
passion there is passion in what we do
there is special looking ahead there is
passion looking at many opportunities
that every day comes from all over the
world so passion is the secret of our
job and when I mean passion is not a
theory passion means to be creative to
look ahead to have also the capability
to be the first client of your product
passion second means vision vision is
something crucial for for your people my
job is to put my people in the best
conditions to succeed and to succeed you
need to give them clear goals clear
priorities I insist on the word
priorities because you can give hundred
goals it's better to give two goals and
achieve these two goals priorities give
them the possibility to understand that
that when some of you as I hope will
come to work in Ferrari
maybe you enter in Ferrari because you
think to do to be an engineering
electronic or to be in the arena
or to be in the management group or to
be I don't know but but maybe after few
months or maybe a couple of years we
have to understand that your attitude is
far better in a different rule like in a
food football team that maybe in the
rules where that you have hired from
Ferrari so when I mean organization I
means clear rules clear responsibilities
clear goals and give to everybody the
possibility the capability that if is
good he can grow up my biggest success
is to see a young student coming in
Ferrari and today maybe the CFO or his
the overall sales a manager or some the
internal growth is the most important
success for a leader but to do this you
need to put your people in best
condition to suceed training open
windows we are in Maranello Maranello is
a fantastic place in which not the same
environment of san francisco one between
the others of the the weather but is a
small place good quality of the life
good food maybe too much maybe too much
so to take care of so some time and not
to exceed and very inside Maranello from
the foundry until the cars be ready to
be shipped all over the world we do
everything inside this is very important
for the human relation is important for
the time market well is important
because I want to take a decision I nine
o'clock in the morning even eight eight
o'clock and I want to see the
application before twelve o'clock this
is a biggest advantage of a company
which dimension means quick decision
rapid decision very rapid tied to market
everywhere third when I mean passion
vision
and third you have to be very demanding
you need you have to put your people in
condition to be I don't say aggressive
because it's not at the corrector word
but to see to see very I want people
that comes in my office with proposals
with ideas with very good ideas
particularly with the workers because we
have 3000 person they are not numbers
each of them has an important rules each
of them has to can can show first of all
to himself and then to us that they are
good days is in condition to solve
problems and also to be creative you
know one of my biggest satisfaction in
my professional wire life was when in -
in 1998 if I remember correct we have
won a financial time important prize the
best place to work in Europe in term of
quality of the life in term of
motivation of the people in term of to
be proud to work for one company but
this means work behind this in this
means also the capability for a leader
to take risks risks are in three
directions
first of all take decisions important
decision looking ahead never looking
back
I mean Ferrari is a very innovative
company I always say I want to maintain
the link with the past with the
tradition with the history but I don't
want to be in the prison of the history
in the past I want to be in the prison
of the future this is a reason why
looking ahead the 360 degrees and when I
mean looking ahead of course technology
product process of course but looking
ahead means new organization means
always to be innovative in why in how we
organize effectually looking ahead in
terms of marketing looking ahead in
terms of how we approach new markets
looking ahead in terms of open the
window to the world because I don't want
to be in the prison of my
Renault I don't want that one of the
plus that we have got the environment
quick decision all together can become a
minus so it's important to have open
windows on the word how through the
suppliers I want the best suppliers in
the world they can give me technology
that can give me experience they can
give me ideas few suppliers but very
very innovative relationship with with
the Research Center even crucial
relationship with universities few but
important innovative University and when
I mean innovative again I don't want to
say innovative only for technologies you
know for me technologies is a bread and
butter if we don't have innovative
technology if we don't to look ahead is
better if we change job for me novelty
innovation means innovation 360-degrees
innovation to open mind of our people
innovation again everywhere but at this
point the rule of the leader is
important when I mean taking risk I
always say to my people listen if I have
one number one in it higher I want to
have good number one in every single
department but if I have a young boy
very good the time in number three is a
listen what I do in a company not so big
I have a number one that is very capable
young fantastic but I'm a good number
three I don't like to be the handle
three or even the number two for the
rest of my life this is something
important in the organization you have
to take risk and some type to appoint a
number three other as a number one you
take a risk you look ahead but if you
succeed you have a young number three
that is a fresh air and is better than a
traditional number one I don't know if I
was clear enough take risk for a manager
for a leader means not only to to be
very demanding with your people but also
to take risk in terms of appointing new
people to let them growth inside the
company and then of course then of
course meritocracy is a key point
we are present in 60 different countries
in the world United States is by far
since fifty years our largest market but
at the end of this year
gray China will be the second UK is the
third Germany is the third UK the fourth
I'm saying this just to give you an idea
of what does it mean we cannot pretend
to control 60 countries format from
Maranello but from the other hand I want
to maintain the exclusivity of Ferrari
Ferrari sells more or less more or less
7,200 cars in the world but maintaining
the same numbers in the each countries
our growth is due to the growth of the
market ten years ago China was small
Emirates was more today they are very
important so our growth in term of
numbers in terms of volumes is totally
related with the growth of the number of
markets but we maintain the same
exclusivity and again the three key
elements of Ferrari are designed Ferrari
has to be beautiful like a good-looking
girl when you see her then-then-then the
difference is the following
because maybe when you go out for dinner
with this good-looking girl
you have a big delusion but with second
point when you start the engine of
Ferrari you have to begin to the earth
so if you put the beauty and the later
it becomes a fantastic product
and when you open there the engine you
have the music of the engine and this is
something important because we don't
sell a car we sell a dream when in 1994
we have sold our first Ferrari in China
I wanted to meet our first client he
came to Maranello he was a guys that
time about 15 55 years old said listen
you want to do a lap in our truck say
yes yes so he did one lap and beside our
coal auditory message a test driver and
he did one entire lap of the Furano
track our private track is more or less
a three-kilometer without a change gear
in first gear and and they and the test
driver was full guy said listen he said
he came to me said listen mister
president
I didn't I was not allowed to change
myself the gear for himself so I was
there hoping the engine didn't blow up
because what then he came to have lunch
with me as a listen he was ready to eat
a Chinese food SL listen I organized
Italian food he was so happy tortellini
past he was so happy I said can I ask
you why you have bought a Ferrari in
China as a first client Indy was a very
nice person he told you know I come from
a very poor family my father was on them
both commercial both good boats around
the world once he came to China with a
book and inside this book of a car book
cars book and I've seen this red car and
I told to myself listen as soon as I
will I will have money and I will have
money because I know that I will suceed
in the life I will buy a Ferrari so you
know for me this is a good answer
when I say we sell a dream not only a
car because when you drive a Ferrari you
have first of all to feel emotion of
driving and
emotional driving is a mix of different
elements that are very key marketing
elements the music of the engine one of
the most important movie classical movie
director came to buy his Ferrari in
Furano in Maranello and then he said
okay I said listen do you want a date I
ship your car to the he was going to
Berlin for the concert do you want a
ship the car to Berlin for you are you
kidding he told me I want to drive
myself the Ferrari from here to Berlin
because listening at the engine music I
am concentrate of my music so you know
these are elements for us the the the
particular elements are crucial our
collusion in the music of the engine are
crucial in the technology are crucial in
the design occlusion in the interiors
are crucial in the introduction of new
colors are crucial 360 degrees and to be
as I am so keen to the particulary
particular I need pick I did people that
follow this I so going back to the three
key elements of Ferrari is beautiful and
this means a design design means to
maintain an important finish with the
past I want I always tell to my people
when we discuss for the white page and
this is the best moment because I can
tell to my people what kind of product I
want and then I tell listen I want a car
that even without the Ferrari brand the
Ferrari a pressing horse in the front if
you see this car in a square in
Stockholm in Los Angeles in Rio de
Janeiro or in Johannesburg this has to
be a Ferrari so I want to maintain what
we call it a little bit family feeling
from the past to the future elements
details these are crucial details these
are crucial in the design is very easy
or it's not so difficult to do a cart
very very innovative
that after two years you getting tired
with this car but is far more difficult
to do an innovative evergreen car this
is important and I was very pleased to
see outside a car that one of your
colleague is lucky enough to have a old
red Daytona acre of the 60 and the car
of today the four five eight Italia
fantastic car I give you some details so
you can be ready to buy this a carton
now
no I'm not here to sell but I'm here to
let you dream so and with all my art I
hope that your dreams will become
reality so design is something extremely
important because again as I said before
the first approach with Ferrari is with
the design again I don't want to repeat
a very popular example as a good-looking
girl is the first approach for all of us
now the second point is technology again
when you start the engine you need
something unique
yesterday in Beijing we have announced
the first Ferrari that we will present
at the end of the year with the curse
with so you will recuperate energy
through the braking this means a 40%
less co2 emission so ecology and means a
boost but because when you push again
the accelerator you have green energy
but very strong for acceleration for me
technology is extreme technology and in
this sense we are the mast winning team
in the history of Formula One we have
started in 1951 July in silverstone
track in england and losing or or
winning since 60 years a red Ferrari is
always there at the start of the Formula
One Grand Prix this is for me the most
important Advanced Research Center and
we have transferred technology very
often from Formula One to our road cars
we have been the first to introduce what
I call the Formula one gearbox it means
a clutch without clutch like a video
game that you can change the gear
without change
they put maintaining the steering wheel
in the steering wheel with
hands and we will launch this curse
it means hybrid car but with huge a huge
performance for me technology is 360
degrees technology and means safety
means innovation means also the
capability to look always ahead last
year we have introduced the first
Ferrari never made four-wheel drive but
this is a normal no there's not the
normal four-wheel-drive and I respect
the German cars
they are fantastic perfectly they are
like a freezer everything perfect
everything perfect but beside the
technology I prefer the red the
technology because is a hotter
technology there is passion behind maybe
sometimes you can have a small problem
but it's better to have some time once
the really small small problem
instead of the freezer so so with all
the respect with all the respect because
I have to say that I think that Porsche
after Ferrari is the best car very good
car I respect and that I respect
particularly I like to respect the b2
the second or the third for me is
perfect I will be more difficult if they
will be the first so we are there so I
respect a lot now now talking quite
serious you know technology means not
maximum speed we don't care anymore of
access speed you can have a small car
with the under 6 or 300 kilometers per
man per my this is not a problem the
problem is acceleration handling safety
timing of braking I love cars in which
even you are very very quick you can
brake in a very short time I like
emotion of driving and this is thanks to
the technology I mentioned to you the
four-wheel drive is not a normal
four-wheel-drive this is 4-wheel Drive
is a
our four seeds this is not I'm sorry I
don't want to promote these to tell you
something is a car four-wheel drive with
660 horsepower is a racing car but there
is not fixed the four-wheel drive the
car when the car needs more grip
automatically through an a computer
center in the car through an electronic
when that the car needs more grip
automatically the car have an a grip in
the bumping asphalt heavy rain ice snow
so it means that we can save a lot of
weight because for us weight is like
horsepower in the engine less weight
more performance and also more safety in
term of braking and so and so so first
of all is design second is technology
and third is what I call innovation in
terms of products innovation is colors
innovation is the interiors innovation
is also a lot of elements that we put on
the car and going back to the leadership
you know the Dean was kind enough to say
at the beginning of 90 I came back to
Ferrari after my racing experience in
the 70 and I felt that since Enzo
Ferrari pass away Ferrari was like a big
actress very famous actress
unfortunately without receive scripts
and offer from the produce from the
movie producer mainly because Ferrari
was in the prison of the past instead
the look ahead and looking ahead means
also for a leader to have sensibility of
what is going on in the worldwide market
today thanks to our presence in 60
markets we have to anticipate a trends
we don't like to be a follower
and to be to anticipate you have to be
curious you know sometime I give to my
people female or fashion magazines say
listen this must became crazy
to give an engineer this is to give them
the feeling of the colors of the
advertising of the taste around the
world because we are a mix between
luxury products we are a mix between
Nike shoes we are a that is not a luxury
product that is a product with
innovation design material and we are a
mix with a high high technology product
and now to make the story shorter I am
sorry because I would love to give you
so many example to talk a lot but I
don't want to take too much of your time
I try to put myself in your position you
were listening at the person like me
that unfortunately is very young inside
but not very young anymore
very much if I can give you some
suggestions I am NOT a teacher I try to
transfer to you my passion my experience
my mistakes my good things because in
the life to take the risk means some
time to make mistake but I prefer people
they take risks making mistake before
instead that people that is always
without taking risk looking ahead and
have proposal creativity and ideas I
think that the globalization today is a
huge huge element if I look at this room
I see young people coming from all over
the world so from one side these
universities has to be proud for the
level to have here people coming to to
learn to be here from coming from all
over the world from the other side
I think that many of you will be back to
your countries with a good experience
knowing good know how and I'm sure with
ideas today if we look at the world I
have been chairman of Fiat for eight
years and that was used to grow very
often to Brazil Brazil we are market
leader is a fantastic country ten years
ago not to twenty ten years ago Brazil
was very well known in the world for
soccer carnival and girls I'm sorry but
this is a picture now I'm not sorry this
is a picture today Brazil the growth of
the Brazil is with two numbers every
year innovation technology young people
fantastic country I don't want to
mention China because we always make the
example of China so this is natural and
I'm happy to see Chinese students here
because they will go back to their
fantastic country with America
experience with this fantastic country I
think maybe the best thing I did in my
life is to study at Columbia because I
was in touch with America with democracy
with the sense of state with the
capability to look ahead with the
capability to open doors to everybody
this is some something unique in the
world so if we have if I have to give
you some small advice be curious be
curious open your mind to the world
reading looking at the television iPad
but not exceed because if not you spend
all your life looking at your iPad and
this is something important technologies
are crucial but be careful because
technology can have a big risk to
equalize the people in term of be using
technology
I want people that can control they can
handle technology they can use
technology but they are not used by the
technology so behind
ma I pad behind the computer behind the
electronic the main power is crucial the
manpower is crucial you have to control
you have to use you have to drive
technology in the direction that you are
looking for but you have not to be
dependent or even more driven by the
technology and the second element is
when I mean curiosity is globalization
gives a port opportunity it's not only
question of job opportunity is question
of mentality mind opportunity ideas from
new market the idea of how can you be
good at working can you approach a new
market internal products this is nothing
to do with Ferraris nothing to do with
cars every kind of product every kind of
product and when I mean marketing of
idea is the capability to use your days
your month here in this university to
take off as much as you can I think that
we are raised we are doing a race in
which we are the pilot and to do a pole
position it means that we have to take
off take out from ourselves the maximum
to succeed and so you know I think that
I hope that at the end of this small
speech you can share with me that we
have fantastic opportunities we have to
believe in ourselves
we have to be good you have we have to
be very determinate we have to be very
demanding with our self we have to be
very demanding without university we can
learn from our roommate of not only from
our professors professors a lot of
things but please again with our respect
of the German technology passion hot
technology hot passion with inside all
of you thank you for your attention
thank you very much
alright Rodrigo Center prema no qualm
I'll graduate school business um I can
tell you from where are you each alley
from where Tonto Trent oh very good
I can't tell you how proud I am that
somebody from my country could come here
and give an amazing speech about
leadership and opportunities and hope
for the future would you talk a little
bit about what it's like to lead a
company in a country where the political
environment is kind of turbulent and the
general culture for entrepreneurship is
not as open as it is here in the in the
valley Thanks well this is good question
because then it gives me the possibility
to transfer to you an experience that
I've got yesterday as I'm sure many of
you I've been always at honest from the
development from nothing of the what we
call Silicon Valley and I was always a
curiosity why here because with all the
respect United States is big why here
and yesterday I've got two hours of a
very interesting under human under human
and professional point of view with mr.
Tim Cook the chief of Apple and I like
to transfer to you something that I
learned yesterday because you know what
is important in the life when you go in
the bed in the night because we have to
go back soon or later in the night
unfortunately or lucky too
is depend and to have learned something
during the day yesterday is today
because you know for me to be here and
to be lucky to see young people like you
therefore I don't know how much of
twenty minutes half an hour ago norm has
been so put so big attention for me is a
big satisfaction I want to thank all of
you for this for my for myself and
yesterday I took two lessons from these
guys from cook and from edco and a decoy
first of all simplicity you know
sometime when in Europe you meet with
some some big chairman a big hero of
management you have to be careful
because they are very proud of themself
or they think to be the champion of the
world
you know I like the simplicity that is
not only way to address the simplicity
in the behavior and to be in touch with
you to talk with you to transfer to you
ideas experience and know-how simplicity
second who is then second the passion
for the work and you see the passion
when you go around a campus incidentally
today I want to say to your Dean that I
think again I would like to find a way I
don't know when and how but I will be
very very happy and pleased to find a
way to organize a couple of days in
Maranello with some students you will
find a way the best but
mr. Dean you have an official invitation
I would love to do your business your
job because I think is a fantastic job
there are many fantastic job but in the
next life I will make them the right
choice for the moment I'm happy of mine
but to find a way and I'm happy to
contribute because I think that in the
globalization to give the students the
possibility to touch with their own
hands
products organization like for me
yesterday to see the campus to see the
product to see how they work because I
am fundamental at my I'm an organizer
I'm not an engineer I'm not a technician
I not very good financial guy but my biz
my job is to end second point the
passion in how they handle not only the
business not only the technology not
only the products but the people and
third I took another lesson yesterday
that when you have got a leader in a
company like you're like steve job is
very nice to see people that has been in
the company with him for a long time
respecting him and having a big respect
and be gratitude for what he has done
because a thanks to his job now they are
in condition to be there this is very
important is a mix between human
elements and professional and so to
answer to your question I appreciate the
Apple particularly because they are very
close to Ferrari brand the position
Emilia the apple and the pressing horse
attention to the brand exclusivity they
don't do many projects for family of
products they do not have many hundred
different products attention to the
people and tension to an environment and
also from Cupertino from the
headquarters they control the entire
world
as we do in Maranello so different
example but a lot of links together so
thank you mr. cook for the fantastic
experience I got yesterday second
question here
Rema Rema due to a breast irregular so
italiana Davi Seattle
Abbey now from one side I'm very happy
to receive question from the Italian
from the other side of the doubt there
are all Italians here order I'm I'm not
Italian I'm in Spanish ah so from where
are you I'm passionate about the sports
and I cannot help ask you about Fernando
Alonso and some leadership traits you
have perceived in your relationship with
him along all these years that's my
question
no this is good question is identity in
my way here a couple of hours ago I
receive a phone call from a fantastic
leader that is Emilio butene from Spain
he has been a guide that from scratch he
has created the number one bank in
Europe Bank of Santander and also
because he's a Ferrari sponsor so I
always said he's the best in the world
the best company the best brand the best
bank fantastic job fantastic
you know this is a good question because
I've been used in my career to be in
touch with three fantastic drivers with
many but these are three super in the 70
nietzsche Lauda from Austria he won two
championship with us and he has loosened
the third for half point because he was
born in an accident so he was
unfortunately he he lose a few races and
few points the second is Michael
Schumacher from Germany he won with us
for championship title and he has
entered in the Ferrari in the Ferrari
history and the third is Fernando Alonso
to be leaders in Formula one means not
only to be a good driver to push in the
race this is crucial to be leader means
be close to the team work during the
week and not only in the race weekend be
mani Akali Menaka how is in English man
yet in the details everything because in
a competition in which you can win or
lose
for half a tenth not for a half seconds
for half then you need to be absolutely
concentrating every single details that
is again is not only the details in
terms of performance because of course
you have to look very carefully how can
improve the start I can improve the
handle of the car I can improve the
pistol its but to be a leader because
Formula one is really a team work and I
forgot to tell you because I don't like
to read my speech was because I have
everything here first of all and here
tip spirit is very important in every
kind of job I don't believe anymore
in the one-man show I don't believe it
in the politic I don't believe this in
the business I need I believe in a
leader that can put together people in
my life I tried all the time to have
with me people far better than me better
than me and I always push my people
don't be jealous
don't hire middle level people if there
is a young guy that is a huge potential
you have to be like a good trainer put
him in the best condition to suceed not
be jealous to suceed team spirit is
fundamental let me give you one
important example in term of management
we are here today is 24 am i right today
of April Wednesday in this moment I have
five or six different big teams inside
the factory working in a different areas
if I look at the competition
only competition and forget road car
that at the end the day for us is even
more important we have a team of people
that is working day and night 24 hours
per day three tours in the wind tunnel
to improve this bloody car that is not
as competitive as I wanted at the
beginning of the season 24 hours per day
fritters people with aerodynamic
know-how a second team is working how to
improve the mechanical area of the cars
when I mean mechanical I mean engine
gearbox suspensions a third team is
working for the car that we will have in
the second half of the season so nothing
to do with the tomorrow race or after
tomorrow for September October November
totally different Department and the
another department is working for the
next year cars
it means different people different
groups but working together with the
coordination and if I think what we are
doing at the moment in the road cars
activity new models new technology and
suppliers a lot so team spirit is
important Fernando Fernando is a driver
that has to is for me is at the moment
particularly in the race the number one
in the world because he's able from the
first lap until the last lap too at the
same time like a qualifying time
fantastic but but the two big strengths
of Fernando is it is always positive
even when he has a not competitive car
he pushed the teams is confident he
gives them support and easier with you
are the best you we will suceed in the
second attention as a maniac of the
details when we have loosened two years
ago in a bloody race in Abu Dhabi for
half point
if I think again I grow a ways and thank
you very much DeRay the championship
after the race I went to the pit and
they sue all my people crying like a
child because to lose at the last race
in that wave and alone so that lose he
was the first to lose went to every
single mechanic and said thank you for
what you for what you did we will suceed
next year
count on me this is very important it's
the same thing that a leader in a
company as to support has to be
demanding if there is somebody that
doesn't doesn't like to work is better
to find another job there is a very easy
way give me a small letter in which you
resign and I'm happy if you don't like
but if you like my goal my job my
activity is to put you in the best
condition to suceed and Fernando is a
fantastic driver and I'm happy to have
him in the team
you
change y cada Vida July's change
organizations gai bian change
organizations definitely I might change
the world